hello everyone I hope you all had an
excellent weekend and welcome to the
longer way that match between allelic
chess zero and the Grandmaster Andrew
tank also known as the penguin GM
unleashes now I would like to say a
couple of things before we actually see
the game the game was played in a couple
of time formats at first they plays do
rapid games then I believe it was a
couple of little games and then also I'm
not sure how many but I believe it's
like eight bullet games or maybe it was
them
oh no I will show you the final results
of all of their games after this game
but this is the same version of Lil hs0
that played the match against EMS and
also the same version of Lee watch a
zero that will compete in the T that
competes in the TCC this season so it's
a very interesting game Lila has the
white pieces here and at one point
actually in a couple of points in the
game I will see that Lila really doesn't
play like a like like a normal engine so
let's see it
Lila has the white pieces and she opens
with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3 knight
c6 and the d4 so alia goes for the
Scorch game he capture Sun before night
capture Sun d4 and knife to f6
we have Knight captures on c6 the shmita
variation B captures and E 5 now the
Misses variation of the Schmidt Queen to
e7 pinning the pawn queen to e2 now
defending the content Knight to d5
we have c4 nice to b6 and here a Lilla
plays nice to be 2 which isn't what well
this night the b6 is actually exiting
the variation here after the c-4 move
the standard the standard continuation
is Bishop trace X simply pinning that
pawn and then white will continue b3 and
so on and so on
here penguin goes for night to b6 and
the leela goes for night to d2 we have
Queen to b6
penguin makes a room for his Bishop to
develop so he can castle and we have
Queen to e4 it seems that after playing
so many games against herself Leela also
learned like alpha zero that it is a
good idea to move your queen more than
once in the opening and okay it's an eye
centralizing move
also making room to develop your bishop
and also getting ready to castle as soon
as possible and here you can go
something like Bishop to e7 or or c5 or
something to Castle quickly because
after Y develops there's really no way
to castle as a white is already
targeting that h7 pawn so penguin goes
for g6 here that this will kind of numb
the Queen's attack on the h7 porn and is
preparing to play Bishop g7 and castle I
will have Bishop to d3 Bishop to g7
castles and now again castles there's a
really no way to capture the pawn here
because of the relatively obvious Queen
captures Bishop captures and rook to e1
now your Bishop can't move it's pinned
you have to defend it and then f4 will
obviously win the piece
so here and rucastles we have Knight to
f3 and Bishop to a6 b3 this move was a
bounce tab but at one point h5 and the
bishop to a3 a little attack stroke on a
faith we have rook F to e8 rook a to e 1
and now d5e characters on d6 and Poisson
and here you can capture the Queen but
capturing the Queen leads to a very
forced variation that's a Bishop
captures on e4 now white is threatening
to capture on c6 and attack both Brooks
but you you have to capture the pawn you
can't allow C captures D captures on c7
so after C captures on d6 bunch of
characters now you have to capture
anyone you don't want to lose the
exchange of rook captures and now attack
the bishop I have to rotate Czech Rock
move rook captures Bishop captures and
now nice the c8 you have to defend this
pawn here this is the only way to defend
it and after Bishop to d7 attacking the
knight that's defending the pawn well
you could defend it with Bishop to f8
but now blacks pieces are aren't very
active this Bishop is looking very silly
on a6 and white is also a pawn off this
is basically a winning position for
white so after this eeeek after some d6
I'm Poisson penguin plays in Queen to d7
opens up an attack from this rook to the
Queen we have Queen moves and now C
captures on d6 recapturing the pawn bit
of characters on d6 and now rook a to d8
attacking the
worship only sex twice and also if the
bishop moves then the bishop and III is
attacked twice so the basically what
what a forced move would be his rook
captures any eight and this is something
that a lot of engines play I've tried to
send a couple of different engines on my
own local engine on an elite chess
engine on chess 24 engine they were play
this rook captures any eight move and
after rook captures rook to d1 and this
seems reasonable you got rid of the
threat you have to change a piece and
you're you're still enjoying your your
your position being up being up on up
but here after this rook a to the 8th
allele that doesn't go for rook captures
and yet rather she plays Knight to e5
Knight to e5 allows penguin to actually
enter enter a position where he has two
pieces for a rope but it's interesting
that
Levada a little didn't go for that move
that to the engine recommend that rather
she goes for this and she evaluates this
as a winning as a winning idea and
you'll see later in fact that she is
she's perfectly correct rook captures an
e5 this is what penguin played and we
have Bishop captures on e5 you can't of
course capture the Queen because the
bishop is guarding the rook but you
could play rook captures on e5 here you
would get a similar position after Queen
captures here now rook to e8 check of
course you don't capture the rook
because the you will lose the Queen
so Bishop to f8 and now Queen captures
rook captures and basically we have a
similar position that did happen in the
game where were our Black has two pieces
for a rook but it's a slightly less
forced after rook captures on e5 Bishop
captures on e5 was played by Leela Queen
captures on d3 now grabbing that piece
and Bishop captures on g7 King captures
and now rook to e7 threatening Queen
captures on f7 and here you could play
rook to a faith to simply defend the f7
pawn button rock after some a7 and black
will be extremely passive here that's
grabbing another pawn that black doesn't
even have material advantage now that
that white is of two points
regardless of having two pieces for the
rook so I have to look to e7 penguin
decides to go Queen to a5 immediately
offer a trade of Queens but now we have
Queen captures pawn captures and h3
first creating some breathing room for
King and now rook to e7 of course you
don't want to allow rook captures an a7
salt roof to roof to d7 rook captures
Knight captures and now rook to d1
attacking the knight nice the c5 and now
rook to d8 now we have Bishop to d7 and
not allowing rook to e8 the grabbed at
pawn
b phi before now allah does not want to
allow andrew to keep this perfect
structure on the Queen side because you
see here the Knight is guarding the
bishop the bishop is guarding the pawn
and c6 and there is no way for the rook
to actually attack the a7 point
so while this is a in this formation
this is perfect for black but
unfortunately for Andrew allah has this
b4 move and here last idea for Andrew
was night to a6 not allowing rook to b8
and after night to a6 Leela could simply
play a three and now you do you still
have two pieces for the rook but they
are two - horrible pieces and you can't
break free for example c5 b 5 is coming
and after night night c7 or something
rook to d7 again wins apiece
so after this before move and replayed
night to e6
we have rook to b8 now attacking the
bishop bishop to a6 and it was in this
position that andrew said okay i will
not wait for Lilith to play b5 and then
I will resign the game and of course in
this traditional illa display b5 and of
course in this position Andrew did
resign the game because he's losing a
piece we have C captures pawn captures
and now the bishop has nowhere to go the
rook is guarding to b5 pawn and wherever
the bishop retreats
it's simply simply gonna be a rook
against a rock against the night with
four points each but black's pawn
structure is simply terrible
so Andrew doesn't want to play this and
after this b5 move he resigned the game
and this was in fact the first game of
the match but I will probably show a
couple of other games
it was very interesting but here I have
the final score this isn't the final
score of the match after the match they
still continued playing they tried out
some different time formats they played
ultra bullet one bullet one minute plus
one second increment one they even
played a zero plus plus two seconds
increment or something like a zero plus
three and in the end the final result
was 40 points Lila and four points
penguin and it was very interesting out
of those four points penguin even won
one game and in that one game Lila
blunders her Queen it was a it was a it
was a pretty childish blunder but they
did play ultra bullet it's like fifty
fifteen seconds each without increments
so it's interesting even in such low
time formats Lila does not behave like a
ninja
so she blundered a queen and in one of
one of other games
she also blundered the Queen but she
managed to win the game because Andrew
was too low on time but yeah it was it
was a very exciting game matched see and
I will put the link to the original
footage from from this match you can
watch the entire thing it's about it's
some three hours long you can watch it
on Andrew tangs youtube channel I do
recommend it it's a extremely enjoyable
and do check it out and I will put a
couple of useful links in the
description as usual so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it like I said I
will probably show a couple of other
games maybe not the one over Leela
blunders the Queen since that's an ultra
bullet game but perhaps you know for fun
why not I would like to thank John
Roberts Emery Jiang
David bacon a lead on a label which and
david marvel for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting game from this match
thank you all